. OK, it's Thursday, meaning we have the latest
jobs numbers.
Plus we have updated first quarter GDP numbers.
It's all pretty ugly, but I will sort of mention
at least a few, possibly less than horrifying
components to some of this data.
First of all, GDP, you might remember that
about a month ago we got
the first quarter GDP estimate, which was
a decline of four point eight percent.
It's now been updated often in the 30 days
after the estimate.
We get an updated GDP number.
The first quarter GDP number has been made
worse by being increased to a five percent
shrinking of gross domestic product during
the first quarter.
Now, in a moment, Locksley net in a moment.
Right now, the White House is planning not
to release expectations for the second quarter.
And this is part of the Proactiv propaganda
attempt to cover up historically unconscionably
bad economic numbers that we are going to
get at the end of July and into the end of
August, during into the end of August, about
the second quarter.
The White House clearly seeing the writing
on the wall and they are not going to be publicizing
these expectations.
They will get them from
their economic teams, but they will not be
publicizing them.
And the numbers for GDP for the first quarter
getting worse from four point eight percent
down to five percent down.
A sign of what is to come.
Now, jobs numbers.
Last week, another two point one million people
lost their jobs.
New unemployment claims last week, two point
one million new unin point unemployment claims
now understand that before coronavirus, 700000
job losses in a week was the record.
I believe it was sometimes sometime in the
80s.
I don't remember if it was 82 or 88.
I've mentioned it before, but losing 700000
jobs in a week was the record for the United
States.
We've now had about 10 consecutive weeks of
anywhere from three to 10 times those numbers,
10 consecutive weeks.
So we now have a first couple of weeks.
It was about six million jobs lost each week,
then five million.
Then around four million jobs for a couple
of weeks.
Then we lost three million jobs a week for
a couple of weeks.
And in total.
Forty one million new unemployment claims
have been made during the era of Corona virus
the last 10 weeks.
Remember that before Corona virus, we estimated
the labor force was about one hundred and
fifty eight million people.
So that means that 26 percent of the total
workforce
in 10 weeks lost their jobs.
Insane, unimaginable economic destruction.
Now, a few things to bear in mind.
This doesn't mean that now 41 million people
are still out of work.
Some of the people who lost their jobs, you
know, nine weeks ago, 10 weeks ago, they've
gotten new jobs.
And in fact, if you look at continued claims,
ongoing unemployment claims, it actually has
come down.
So two weeks ago, we were at 25 million active,
unemployed people.
That is now down to twenty one million.
So that's something.
It means that in the last week, more people
got off of unemployment than the number that
got on.
The most likely scenario based on these numbers
is that we are going to see very high unemployment
numbers for a very long time, even if every
state was able to reopen today to 75 percent,
you would still see very big numbers continuing
certainly into 2021.
And there are questions about could this be,
you know, a two year recovery?
Could this be a five year recovery?
We just don't know.
But the point is, forget about this being
fixed to any significant degree before the
November election.
And this is why yesterday's segment about
garbage math is so important, because there
is a good chance that after disastrous second
quarter numbers, we will start to see some
improvement from these.
Absolutely.
You know, bottom, bottom, bottom lows in the
third quarter.
And as we start to see that recovery in the
third quarter, hopefully if we just continue
straight on wave one and wave to blend together
and things continued to worsen, this may not
happen.
But if you start to see some improvement in
the third quarter, the administration is going
to start to focus on growth rates.
I already told you now they're floating.
Air travel reservations are up.
One hundred and twenty percent.
Well, yeah.
But they were down to just four percent.
Right.
They were down 96 percent.
They are now recovering from being only four
percent of what they were.
So the base rate matters.
We've talked before yesterday about how this
will impact propaganda around GDP numbers,
propaganda around jobs and unemployment numbers.
So I want things to improve as rapidly as
possible.
But I also don't want to get bamboozled into
thinking that things are better than they
actually are, nor into being bamboozled into
believing that Donald Trump fixed something
that he actually had nothing to do with.
So the numbers are clearly going to keep getting
worse before they get better, including in
the quarter.
We're currently in the second quarter.
We won't know how bad it got this quarter
until around August 1st or even September
1st.
The official dates for Q2, GDP, our estimate,
I believe, on July 30 and update on August
30.
So be prepared.
Be prepared.
Is the point.
And don't fall for garbage math as we will
undoubtedly be subjected to by this administration